inmates in the united states are staging
what could become the largest prison
strike in American history the peaceful
protest which is now into its second
week is planned last 19 days and
encompasses 17 states prisoners are
demanding an end to what they call
modern slavery and for the introduction
of a number of reforms
[Applause]
[Music]
a several American departments of
Corrections claim there have been no
sign of any strikes and their
institutions we have asked for written
confirmation of this despite reports we
have not had any organized stoppages
protests or lock dance related to the
strike at our institutions there are no
strikes occurring in Georgia the GDC is
prepared should that change we have been
and will continue to monitor the
situation only hide Correctional
Institution in Swann quarters salt
protests inmates were allowed to hang
banners from the inside fencing a human
rights activist celinda good guerrero
claims some facilities have used violet
measures to stop the strikes Angola
prison who I've been I was organizing
with were taken to administrative
segregation in one case one of the
organizers was shackled by his ankles
and drugged across the prison as a
message to the rest of the institution
states like New Mexico and many others
what they did is they began lockdowns of
all facilities and kept all inmates in
isolation and they're in their
individual cells as a mechanism for
stopping activity
you